And to show you exactly what's going
on here, I have a little scene.
I've taken the images,
tried to animate them so
you can see what's happening, okay?
So here's a very sort of ugly scene.
It's sort of color coded
by certain regions.
That doesn't really matter.
What matters is the camera now
is going to move to the right.
All right, it's a posterized co,
color scene so you, so
you can see these things
stand up a little better.
Right, so that's image one,
that's image two, that's image three,
that's image four.
So going backwards, so
the camera's moving to the right and
of course, the, it's not a Rubik's cube,
whatever kind of horrible evil,
diabolical puzzle that is moving to
the left faster cause it's closer.
So if I were to take all those
images and build a cube of them,
this is that same cube, okay?
So here we have X and Y, and
we stack them in time this way.
And here's just the top of them.
And I'm just going to take a slice,
one of the slices through there, and
that looks like that.
So now it's at a fixed y value.
This is X, and this is time,
and here are my streaks again.
Okay.
And notice that some of these streaks,
okay,
move at different slopes.
Those slopes correspond to
the depth of the scene.
And what's kind of cool about this
is it's really easy to find these
kinds of lines, okay?
And you can find lines that intersect
that, that aren't parallel to the other
lines, and so you can use that to
pull out the object, all right.
This is called EPI, EPI, image analysis.
And you can use that in some other ways
also, so I think one of the coolest ones
I ever saw was done by in the same
some we spoke about before.
Again, now almost 20 years ago,
they had a scene where you had
people just walking past you.
Okay.
And imagine you've now got
a volume of video.
Okay, and you stack that up.
And now I'm just going to show you
some chunks taken from, sort of,
the top, the, the head area,
and then by, down by the feet.
At the area that is really at the very
top here, nothing changes in the camera.
So, as time goes this way,
the pixels stay constant, okay?
But at the slice where their heads are,
okay.
You see these lines there,
the, these regions here?
That's the movement of their
heads through spacetime.
That's what this volume is,
it's spacetime, right.
And so each one of these diagonal
lines is the movement of their heads.
And these straight lines here,
what are those?
Those are just the background
just like up here.
Those, when things don't move, right?
And the camera's moving, these, the, the
pixel value in time stays the same so
it's just a straight, ray and spacetime.
But if they're moving then you
see them moving across in time.
Now the really cool thing is what
happens if you look at their feet.
Right?
So if I look down at this level, okay?
Here's what the spacetime
image looks like.
And you see this braided pattern?
That braided pattern is
the movement of their feet in time.
In fact, they even published a paper,
here's just some images taken
of it showing the same thing,
the slice through the head and
the slice through the, the feet.
And what they were able to show, and
here it's just sort of lined up,
is that you could actually recognize who
the person was with a small sample set
by just tracking that braid, all right.
So look, if not how you would do
gate recognition in a really good
discriminative way and things like that.
But it's an example of showing
you the data structures
that you can get from processing video.